tous s qui avait valu six jours de fête
nationale à dreux départ de la 8e étape
du tour de france la caravane passe les
cyclistes sont dans la place avec
quelques têtes bien connues en centre
val de loire suis pas très loin de chez
moi malheureusement n'y a pas beaucoup
des tapis qui passe dans le centre mais
voilà ça fait toujours plaisir de voir
des gens que j'ai l'habitude de voir la
famille des amis donc formé à
saint-amand-montrond jugan n'oublie pas
ses racines tout comme nos autres
représentants une dizaine dans
l'organisation 21e tour pour le plus
expérimenté nicolas dubois qui n'hésite
pas à recruter sur ses terres du
loir-et-cher et aux alentours
mettant un peu chauvin quand même on
essaie de faire rentrer les personnes
qui ont les compétences et le charisme
pour tenir un rôle au sein des sceaux
traversée de la ville avant de quitter
dreux eure-et-loir et la région devant
un public conquis et gâter les
madeleines ce qui l'attend est longue au
tour de france la colle
le soleil
par les temps qui courent c'est très
très pratique et pas mal hein j'avoue
que c'est très joli c'est très pêchu ici
la fête du vélo se termine cette du
football peut commencer
mais sans neymar laissé tomber j'ai
oublié de vous montrer mes
oui demain obligatoires après le vélo le
foot quoi 3 pour la france
mélo ou foot monsieur danilo ce bon à
part si c'est pour supporter la france
de vélo le foot doigts pour que la
france gagne
voilà la france gagne on gagne demain
bien sûr évidemment évidemment début
d'année faible
ouais
bon
au brésil 98 3 0 france croatie 2018
patience on y est presque